so now here I am saying Best New Artist
nominee at the Grammy Awards I am not
surprised whatsoever I know you told us
that the American Music Awards that you
were in complete shock has it sunk in
yet so thank you I think uh many people
are not understanding that much this
nomination because they've seen me in
another like background but for me it
makes complete sense I decided to like
start from the zero again another
territory I'm from Brazil and like I I
say that a lot of times but it's because
it's really different when you come from
a place like that like last time we had
a Brazilian a position like this was 57
years ago five seven like more almost
like more than five decades and uh it's
there are a lot of reasons you know like
a lot of things that you get a give up
to come here and and it takes more time
than like other people people for you to
maintain your people so far away you
know it's it's very particular career I
think oh my goodness all the sacrifices
you have to make and the journey to get
here I'm so proud of you and so happy
for you on the big night on Sunday who
are you going to share the night with
who is your plus one do you get more
than a plus one can you have a plus two
three I'm gonna be with my brother this
is here I'm always with my brother he
was the one who supported me in my whole
career we do we've done the things kind
of like very independent way like very
like a long-ish and uh for me it's
important to have him with me in such a
such a big night because he was the one
who was with me since
the zero oh my goodness I'm very close
with my brother too so to hear you say
that that's you got to keep it within
the fan yeah do you have your red carpet
look picked out because we know you
always bring the looks I kind of do and
then I do not I I changed mine last
minute I don't know I'm not I don't know
to be honest yet I tried something today
and then I think tomorrow went it was
but then I like to just change it look
at new things I don't know what's the
vibe that you want on Sunday like when
you step out on that red carpet as the
best new artist nominee like what do you
want people to
get like feel from that look like I am
here hello I have no idea to be honest
that's why I'm so like confused for the
first time like I like to
what I like to bring more of the times
and I think that's one of them it's to
just feel like I am the jewelry and not
nothing else not the dress it's just me
like I could be here wearing like oh I
can be here like wearing a jeans and a
white shirt and I can just Shine That's
what I think literally shine my friend
yeah I think that's what real artists
are it doesn't matter what you put on
them they get a shine and I like to send
this message like I can wear nothing and
look
[Music]